[ Theme music plays ]
-Hey, just a short one today.
I know we're all upset
when they're not longer.
But we can only correct
the mistakes we make.
If we don't make
a ton of mistakes,
we can't do
a long "Corrections,"
because we're not -- I'm not --
ever gonna pad this out.
Okay?
[ Laughter ]
Because if "Corrections"
is about anything,
it's about integrity,
and we're never gonna do that.
I would argue, there's nothing
on TV that I've seen
that has more integrity
than "Corrections."
It should be noted,
I don't watch a ton of TV.
It's just so...
It's all so woke.
[ Laughter ]
We talked a lot
about the documents
that President Biden kept
next to his Corvette.
Did a joke about Ferris Bueller
stealing his Corvette.
A lot of you said,
Ferris Bueller
stole a Ferrari, not a Corvette.
Sure, but if Cameron's dad
only had a Corvette,
I think Ferris Bueller
would have seen that.
I don't think it was specific
to that kind.
I mean, would Ferris not have
gotten on the float
if the songs weren't
"Danke Schoen"
and "Twist and Shout"?
Look, I get how this happens,
right?
You guys see a mistake,
and you race to your computers.
"Actually, we're already
at our computers."
O-O-Okay!
[ Laughter ]
But [Sighs] you gotta...
slow down sometimes.
Okay?
Life moves pretty fast.
[ Laughter ]
And if you don't stop and
look around once in a while...
[ Laughter ]
...you miss it.
[ Light laughter ]
Alright, we had a joke --
a California man
recently got out of his car
to take a phone call
and returned to find the vehicle
had been crushed by a boulder.
I think we have a picture
of the guy.
Showed a picture of Road Runner.
Joke works, by the way.
No complaints in the audience.
[ Light laughter ]
But then a bunch of you said,
"You know,
wouldn't have been
the Road Runner's car
that got ruined by the boulder.
Based on the mythology
of the Coyote and Road Runner,
it probably would have been
the Coyote's car
that got crushed by the boulder,
not Road Runner's.
One person, though,
said something
that really stuck with me.
He made that argument and
said the Coyote's car
would be destroyed
by the boulder,
and then the Road Runner
would come over
and say whatever obscenities
they had to meep out.
[ Laughter ]
Which I never in my life
considered.
[ Laughter ]
I thought the Road Runner
was saying, "Meep meep,"
but now I'm realizing
it was Warner Bros. censoring
whatever obscene thing.
So, this is what
you would normally see.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Whistle ]
[ Thud, clatter ]
-Meep meep!
-And so we went --
We sent our researchers out...
[ Laughter ]
...to find an uncensored --
again, didn't even know
it was censored --
the uncensored original version
of that same scene.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Whistle ]
[ Thud, clatter ]
-Back up!
[ Laughter ]
-[ Clears throat ]
We oft make jokes
about how Vladimir Putin
is prone to defenestrating
his enemies.
And we made a joke about someone
falling out
a fourth-story window.
Someone wrote that a fall
from a fourth-floor
wouldn't kill you.
Studies show, eighth floor
is what you need to be sure.
And I believe that
because our offices
are on the eighth floor.
But when we started our show,
NBC offered us
far more beautiful, sprawling,
modern offices
on the fourth floor.
And I remember, I didn't
understand why at the time.
I remember Shoemaker saying,
"That's not high enough."
[ Laughter ]
I did throw a little shade
last week at people
for not knowing how to spell
the name Shoemaker,
because it is in the credits
every night.
And then a bunch of you
pointed out,
"We only watch 'Corrections,'
and there are no credits
in 'Corrections,'"
which is very fair.
But, you guys, you gotta
watch the show on NBC.
[ Laughter ]
Just turn the volume down.
Put it on and go to bed.
That's all that matters.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
MGM lion roar --
looked it up.
Somebody said it.
Looked it up. It's true.
Since 1980,
it's actually been a tiger roar,
because tigers have
fiercer roars.
And so this was a decision
that was made by, you know,
whatever MGM's, I guess,
Mike Witzer is.
Um, so, let's -- You get --
So, here's the roar.
Let's take a listen.
[ Lion roaring ]
And I, of course --
I'm no expert
on this sort of thing,
but I was told,
if you could slow it down,
you can hear --
you can tell
that it's not a lion.
Let's take a listen.
-[ Slowed down ] Rowr.
I'm a tiger.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Sucks lips ]
Mentioned
a mid-century credenza,
and, um, a bunch
of furniture heads...
[ Light laughter ]
Somebody literally said,
"I don't know
what century that is."
[ Laughter ]
Look, if you want to sit down
and write something
about the verisimilitude
of a credenza's
date of construction,
you don't have to.
[ Laughter ]
Talked about the rewrite we got
on a really good
Amelia Earhart joke.
And then someone talked about
how they had --
There's a couple
of Amelia Earhart statues.
There's one in North Hollywood,
and somebody wrote
a very long comment
about their friends --
them and their friends
watching it get built
and having no idea who it was
while it was getting built.
And now I think
it's also at Purdue University.
But they said it's remarkable
this is what they went with
for Amelia Earhart.
So, that's the statue
of Amelia Earhart.
And I will say,
based on what happened,
it seems weird to make a statue
where she's holding
part of the plane that should
definitely be attached.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell" --
I've never noticed this.
The opening graphics,
a piece of tape
goes over my mouth,
but it is the sound
of tape getting
pulled off a mouth.
Take a look.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
[ Tape tearing ]
We found a solution, though.
Let's take a look.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
-[ Roars ]
Tape going on.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sucks lips ]
This next one is a little tough
to talk about.
Um, yesterday's mono.
[ Inhales deeply ]
We had this joke
"and finally."
"And finally," by the way,
when that's in the joke,
that means it's the closer.
So that --
there's no joke coming
to sort of clean it up.
"And finally, the world's
oldest known person,
a French nun, has reported died
at the age of 118.
And I got to say,
I'd feel pretty bad
if I was the one
who bought her that skateboard."
[ Light laughter ]
That joke did not go well.
[ Laughter ]
And obviously,
it's always tragic --
To explain ourselves,
it's always tragic
when someone passes away.
I would argue,
it's the least tragic
when that person dies
of natural causes
at 118 years old.
[ Light laughter ]
I mean, the last few years,
you could even argue
they're just showing off.
[ Light laughter ]
But the mistake was, guys,
that I cannot defend,
uh, we showed a picture.
[ Laughter ]
You can't --
You can't show a picture.
I mean...
how in God's name
did we think a laugh
was forthcoming
when we put that up...
[ Laughter ]
...for the audience to see?
[ Clears throat ]
[ Sniffles ]
I'm not gonna say
who wrote that joke,
but I am gonna say
that when I told it,
I was...
-♪ Shot down ♪
[ Singing indistinctly ]
-Raised Catholic.
[ Laughter ]
P.O. box [Clears throat]
Sometimes it's great.
Maya knit this for me.
Wrote a very nice letter.
"Here's a draft
that you can have."
That's the sort of reason
we have the P.O. box.
Meaningful gifts
that can be added
to our menagerie
of lovely things.
This is the kind of thing,
I can't stress enough,
I don't want any more.
Talked about Mac Tonight.
We talked about how distressing
I find Mac Tonight.
This is a piece of original art
that once I have seen,
I can't unsee this.
Like, what is this even...
[ Laughter ]
What are you trying to say?
Are we the same person?
Is his evil inside of me?
[ Laughter ]
When he goes on a rampage...
Is that blood on mine hands?
[ Light laughter ]
Do I turn into him...
unknowing to myself?
Does the transformation begin
every time I see half a wolf?
[ Laughter ]
That joke's gonna wax on you.
Well, [Clears throat]
like I said,
it was a short one this week.
And we do not pad.
Not now, not ever
do we pad "Corrections."
So you will see me next week.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Don't show the...
-Meep meep.
-...picture!
[ Looney Tunes theme music
plays ]
♪♪